F your L
G fix your logo
hi all right
uh what do we
feel question what are you
feeling yes
um as n sometimes I feel like I can get
somewhat of a release
going uh upper body but still really
struggling with the lower body
especially the glute and the C and and I
do think that comes afterwards
okay some other
things yeah feel the um this tension
coming in then trying to release out of
it and feeling kind of goes and then
coming back fluu okay and so it's in
that upper arm shoulder area bicep area
okay Maya are you feeling that too yeah
my Delta okay yeah in the deltoid so
you're at a later phase where you can
relax and release the shoulders but the
lower legs is there so the first thing
and I agree the very first place is you
have to learn how to release the the the
arms the upper torso um so let's address
that okay so
um and again this is a progression drill
to cultiv skill in beginners it's not
necessarily how you do it uh and and
it's definitely not how you would apply
it in an application field okay so what
I want you to do um is I want you to
turn your elbow underneath elbow
underneath don't have the elbow on the
side if you pay attention when your
elbow is on the side you actually
violated the Y Line it's outside your
outer rim it's a very common mistake
this is very comfortable to us and so
we're used to doing that but you already
wrong okay you turn that elbow
underneath I'm not asking you to drop
his hand there I just make sure the
elbow's underneath you see that
okay and now make sure that you keep it
in katatori
articulation don't come back so two
mistakes is your elbows on the side
you're going to activate that just just
automatically it's going to happen okay
and then you come back and your bicep is
going to do it you combine the two and
you get two okay so we are going to
start at the physical level for the
person getting going okay and your
elbow's going to be
underneath and you're going to keep the
katatori
angle so he's going to go and this is a
lot of skeletal alignment it's fine as
you start to feel it's going out I don't
know if you can tell you just pull it
back under pull it back under pull it
back under and your goal is going to be
hey just keep this shape keep that shape
keep that shape keep that
shape that's that's going to be your
thing I don't want you to entertain
anything about releasing or anything
you're going to just get skeletal
alignment first elbow underneath
angle so how much do I bend my elbow
that's that's what you're doing there
okay we're here hit that shape the next
thing you can work on is with the
skeletal alignment is the ground
vectoring so you should feel it
here going to feel it on that ground
midfoot on the back foot so as he's
pushing the skeletal alignment you're
putting it on the back foot it's on the
back
foot you not I don't want you bracing
anywhere
else with skele with your skeletal
alignment okay I don't want you in this
step I have this and I keep
this make sure though because you're
going to get a lot of
pressure coming into that
shoulder and as you try to get it to
your foot he'll start to rotate you you
see he's push pushing it that way so
keep your shoulders and your hips Square
to each other no don't turn this way cuz
he'll override the torque you're using
on your torso here shoulders hips almost
like I'm
sideways okay I do that elbow
underneath katad D midfoot and as much
as he pushes I never let this happen
keep the hips and shoulder
alignment he's pushing and you're just
working on these things elbow
under kador articulation on the elbow
shoulders and hips in align and midfoot
that's all you're doing okay you will
feel muscle tension but he won't he
won't be able to override you at much
higher levels than when you're at you
should not feel this or this though okay
let's try that try it
again close your armpit
by by just turning the elbow stay there
I don't want you to turn for I'm not
doing that just bring this in more now
keep the extension on the elbow so when
you brought it in your elbow bent more
keep katatori keep
it and this
armpit area should be closed but don't
bend your arm to do
it more
extension more
extension
there keep it there use whatever muscles
you have to to keep it
there and you drive more
Maya drive you just keep it there
extension elbow extension don't let that
bicep get
activated then you do the other
side extension just pushing your hand
closer to your body use your muscles to
keep your hand the right distance from
it
midfoot Vector on the back foot
shoulders and hips
locked can drive
more just keep these
tasks elbow
underneath shoulders hips midfoot on the
back
foot so your elbows bending stick your
hand further out out in
space keep it out
there it's
bending reach more past the
grip look look past
him and touch touch my fingers touch
them they're right there there you go
good we do it without the imagination
tray okay so that's that's where I
start using my Skillet to line you are
still learning how to get it vectored to
your foot it's not
being
uh it's not in the alchemical process
but it's still going there in other
words as he pushes it's not in my my
shoulder and going over the top of my
foot you are still learning a skill of
the internals okay don't get don't ever
get confused though and think I need to
have my elbow under I'm supposed to have
my armpit closed and uh I'm supposed to
have that articulation angle degrees of
K you don't have to the outer shape is
not important okay but it gets us as a
cultivating tool in the ballp part and I
do learn one skill that I will use
continuously and that is how to take
this energy that's going straight over
there and revor it so that it's going
down
okay and now from
there you start to release the muscle
tension that you're using to keep that
shape okay I task you with the shape and
it's the holding of the form that allows
you to practice the releasing of the of
within that form you have to do both I
give you a shape and now I tell you keep
the shape and don't use Muscle tension
okay you you might not be able to do
this today okay but others of you can so
the first place I want you to notice is
in your uh intuitive currently intuitive
understanding the shape that I actually
to keep and the vectoring that I ask you
to do has nothing to do with your hand
tension my hand is on the other side of
the engine you get it so nothing should
fall apart if my hand dies my hand is
not related this he's pushing my hand is
not related to what I'm doing everything
my wrist his grip is just floating in
space
okay that's the first place I'm going to
do everything get everything where it is
at the beginning usually are like that
you have all that hand tension and when
in you but there's no way that the hand
tension has anything to do with anything
so he's going to push really hard my
hand is pretty freaking loose there's
nothing in my hand which is why I can
keep L gong see but I don't want you to
do L gong right now cuz you're doing the
iido version of it which is a
degeneration too much tension I want you
to to he's going to push you're going to
do
everything and your hand is very loose
for Drive
buddy very loose I keep the same shape
the same form the same ground vectoring
and it has nothing to do with what's on
the other side of this Bri okay let's
try
it make sense there's no way whatever
you're doing with your hands has any
mechanical involvement Okay
Go Okay so the
Ben extend got more right go back where
you were you you
okay don't you can't lose the shape do
you understand yes I'm okay and then you
go and my whole hand needs to be loose
without losing the shape you you look
very uncoordinated there's a lot of
tension in there that there's nothing in
my fingers but there's nothing here
there's nothing here
okay keep the shape otherwise the
contrast doesn't work
okay okay so if I was loose my hand
would go this way too your hands only
going your hands only going here but it
should go it's just loose Let go please
relax relax this is what your hand
should look like okay yes okay hold
that however I don't want you to do the
magic trick so as he's pushing and I go
like this he can't ever get a vector do
do you understand that so I I have to
try to keep that line and then my hand
is loose you see how I try to leave that
still but you can see it's
uh just in that little area going all
over the place okay this isn't it
go okay it's it's
loose loose okay but don't take away his
Vector CU then he can't get the power
that we want which is part of the form
okay try it again losing the elbow Bend
come back out come back out is the arm
tired go to the other arm
fix your head put it
straight shoulders and hips midfoot bend
your back leg don't lose the elbow Bend
extend more reach your fingers like I
had you keep your head straight that's
tension in your neck so you tilt it left
or right it doesn't really matter where
you're looking you should look at him
but don't tilt it left or
right bend your back leg so we know
you're ground vectoring
it's losing the elbow Bend you have to
keep
extending keep extending and go to the
other side don't do it too long okay
it's still pretty
muscular okay just as a we'll move on
and you just have to work there until
you get that until you get that okay um
I'm doing that then the next progression
was hey take take out tension out of out
of the hand it's not relevant okay
um the next one is because the hand was
not relevant to the form to the
structure I've been tasked with then I
can keep any shape with it and the shape
you want is laong okay and laong you can
let go this is
laong so I'm going to spread the
metacarpal
metacarpal okay the fingers are going to
flare not by me moving the
fingers by me opening the
metacarpal I open them until I feel
tension going past the opening of them
to the fingers and or to the forearm and
this is
lon so when he grabs now I keep
L because my hand is not relevant to the
structure on keep so I task myself with
with LA okay he's now driving I keep the
same elbow Bend I keep that elbow
underneath and I'm still on the midf
fooot okay and I don't bring tension
into L gong because then it would not be
L gong you do you understand that so
that would look like this this this is
not right or this he's squeezing me and
you're no that's not L gon this shape of
my hand was not relevant so I keep L
long so the feeling in this hand he's
pushing this whole time I'm talking and
the feeling in this hand is exactly the
feeling in this hand as if he's not
pushing at all okay all right let's try
it keep keep these two especially
there's the only reason they come in is
cuz you're relaxed but I actually have a
shape and an intention there
right so careful over here how they come
in right don't let them come
in
better too much tension you
see I don't move those I move these open
them and those stay where they are from
me opening them don't move
these okay stay like that this hand's
not in it see how they're curling in yes
open more not your
fingers open these and that fingers are
where they
are all right go questions uh I heard
someone mention that they feel it in
their uh
calves I don't know that I have the
awareness in my body to feel it in the
calves yet but I definitely feel it in
the swimmer muscle right in the front of
the shin at Min one when I start asking
for a lot more and get pressed and then
have to try to that's where I feel it
and then have to yeah try to release
yeah I if you pay
attention uh I would say it's like from
the lower
back uh the lumbar region down so it
goes through the glutes through the
groins uh through the upper legs through
your knee joints all your lower leg all
the way down to your feet is where the
tension is so we've been you you right
you've been working lately on keeping
your
metatarsals on flat fed you see so your
metatarsals are flexing then the tendons
running through the lower leg are tense
okay um so yeah where where you feel the
tension is very much related to your
awareness of the tension so the tension
is happening so for example when your
feet were flexing and going all over the
place you really weren't aware of it
until relatively recently do you see it
was doing it all these years but you
weren't aware of it so you have an
awareness level that's feeling it there
but you should know it's from the lumbar
region down okay and someone might feel
it more in the lower legs as opposed to
from the lumbar region down does that
make sense okay so it's all there now
you just have to work with where's your
awareness so start there it's in the
lower half of the body we know that so
you you're aware of the one on the front
of the lower leg okay start there you're
also aware of the one running through
the foot so start there and as you get
more awareness and you start
problematizing that flexion you're going
to see ah it's from the lumbar down
because you're going to go from region
to region as you get get there okay so
just work from there okay where where
did you
have noticing the the sort of down
spiraling capacity in any one rep if the
thought came in oh I'm not getting it it
became very hard to pull out of that
thought and try to back into the Rel yes
it is so if you look back at what the
teacher
said where should your mind
be where's my mind just today's lesson
where's my mind
the hand and the elbow and the geometry
and the form do you got it so don't
don't go outside of that if you are
going uh for your level you would have
been at the LA gong level okay at at uh
Maya's level I just want the the first
intro okay so you're going to go uh
laong
elbow katatori articulation angle uh
midfoot Vector shoulders and hips and it
just Cy through there if you're cycling
through there there's no room for I'm
not making it do do you get that so I
just want you to cycle there okay if you
feel like you're having your partner
push harder to test your form right it
still stays on those things so let's say
you worst case scenario you get knocked
over you shouldn't is still thinking I'm
I'm
elbow midfoot
do you get it you're not going off on
not making it you just fly go backwards
and you just keep yourself on there okay
anything else all right let's try uh
different partners and
go
okay so I start with this the the
intuitive skeletal alignment but I am
ground vectoring okay now if you pay
attention as irrelevant as what was on
the other side of the grip is what's in
front of the elbow is irrelevant to just
we think it we think it's not we think
it's not okay meaning if my elbow
collapsed no matter how much tension I
had out here he'd get me okay so what
we're going to do is your partner is
going to help you so I'll demonstrate
how the UK does this like get him to the
last position so he fixes L
okay all right I'm driving I'm driving
and the B ially I'm going to take the
wrist pressure with the other hand so
it's like traed you see that okay then
I'm going bring the other hand to the
Elbow he's going to leave his elbow in
space exactly where it is and he's going
to slowly Bend his arm to give me the
pushing ledge on the elbow and now he
can relax the whole of the arm but I
don't want you to undo cuz L gong is not
tension okay and now I'm driving and
nothing should change drop it nothing
should change and then I want you to go
back he's going to extend his
arm you're not over there I'm
pushing nothing should
change come
on okay so it looks like this
here like this I have my
alignment he's only not pushing me over
because my elbow's not moving up he
slowly starts to trade pressure points
and allow he com to my elbow now and
then I give him the elbow he's pushing
on the elbow pushing on the elbow and
then like nothing's Chang nothing CH I
don't start going like this like you did
keep exactly where it is I keep the same
and we go back came
from and I don't change anything about
what I'm do okay all right try
it don't don't Flur your elbow out keep
it inside this the hand
comes get to the out get to her elbow
line and now start relaxing your whole
forearm
she'll come back she'll offer the hand
back and you start taking
it don't change
anything when you walk back like that
you're taking pressure off Chris you see
and you're it's you don't want to change
your pressure not your vector not your
degree not your
amount and start relaxing that other arm
your elbow's going down your elbows
going
down I'll do it again okay so here's
that same line the line that would
normally take me
over my elbows in space we can go a
little quicker so we so my elbows in
space I leave my elbow there as as if my
hand was there you see I I come
back I don't want to start going like
this you see that it just stays in space
as if I was there I would prefer you
keep L gong because L gong is not
tension but you need to experiment
remember we did this before we went to
laong keep it all relaxed on your disc
when you're ready start to put your hand
back and he keeps the same pressure and
you don't change anything you go
back don't let this happen also don't
start getting turned
in keep the same shoulder hips stays
exactly the same it's very loose don't
wiggle it so much that he can't get
Force his Force Vector but it's
loose okay and now it goes he keeps it
nothing changes okay try it again it
again uh I'm feeling most muscle tension
in the upper arm doing that transition
from katata to giv the elbow and then
back again it comes the tension comes
back where so when you put your your
forearm back out where do you feel the
tension then uh the upper arm the upper
arm okay so then that tension was there
the whole time okay so that's why you
have to do the other you have to do the
other drill you got to get the other
drill okay we have different levels here
does everyone understand that and so
we're
progressing as soon or later you're not
going to be able to progress okay so but
you have to get the first skill okay so
if I remember uh as we were going back
through these progressions I'm
reflecting back you still couldn't keep
your elbow in katatori
okay and that's very important because
your elbow in
katad in in the beginning progressions
it was looked at a degree of
rotation but in this progression since
you don't have a forearm it's looked at
as how far away is your elbow from your
torso do you see that so as you increase
the degrees of rotation in your elbow in
the earlier progressions your elbow is
now closer to your
body and because your upper arm is a
lever around an axis the shoulder it's
getting lower which we corrected on you
on the last little coaching right I came
to you and I said don't let it go down
it's going down okay so we don't you
could look at it either way don't bring
your elbow down don't bring your elbow
close to your body don't increase the
degrees of articulation in your elbow
that it's all the same problem okay so
you need to figure out uh where is that
Groove so to speak where is that
organization that your teacher wants you
to be in well the best progression for
that is the earlier the earlier ones
okay we are now at a point where you
didn't have your elbow where it needs to
be meaning you did not have the
prescribed or organization and so now
this drill is not doable so you got to
go back okay got it everyone understand
that okay any other questions or
comments there's nothing wrong with
those earlier drills you got to get it
you got to get the skill but we have
other levels here so we're moving on
okay so here's the
thing um if he's if he's pushing and we
come up to the uh come up to the elbow
and we come up to the elbow and my arm
is not holding me in
space then clearly muscle tension was
not important in my in my forearm do you
understand was it it's not important you
can just keep the elbow in space I just
keep the elbow in space that's what I
just proed okay but the same thing as
the elbow is related to the uh to the
wrist if I if my elbow collaps in space
then it's not going to matter how much
tension I put in the forearm the
shoulder works the same way so if the
shoulder can't be strong then the
elbow's not strong you see that so we'll
climb up okay and if you need to I don't
care how relaxed you are but if you can
L gone you keep loud gone cuz loud going
is relaxed do we climb up I'm going to
do a little quickly so the video is not
too long and he'll climb up to the
shoulder and I keep the same feeling and
I you can be
here right you kind of just relax if you
need to relax because the arms are not
relevant to what I'm doing and then we
go out which means I got to
refine where it
is and we climb back out push push push
we climb back out okay I'll do it again
as if I started the drill he's driving I
start to give him the elbow I give him
the elbow he's driving I start to give
him the
shoulder nothing changes he's pushing
push push push push push push push push
push push push everything is just going
down there's no leaning or anything I'm
just here and then I want you to come up
give him the elbow keep everything the
same and you come out I'm doing it
faster than I want you to do it and
you're back out okay so there's no
tension involved if there was tension I
wouldn't be able to take the arms away
we just don't fig we haven't figured
that out yet okay but it's the clear
scientific experiment that muscle
tension had nothing to do with it in the
arm had nothing to do with it there's a
structural Integrity in the shoulder
obviously but it's not in the arm you
got that so just kind of be a
kinesiologist or physiologist right now
where is the tension that's keeping the
shoulder in
space it's not in the upper arm it's not
in the shoulder muscle it's not in the
forearm it's not in the half what's
keeping the shoulder in
space yep Bouch you got it the whole
freaking structure here got it to just
hold the structure which is what you
were supposed to do here in the
beginning but we were like nope it's got
to be my hand it's got to be my forearm
it's got to be my upper arm it's got to
be my OU outer delto it's not just my
whole body here okay so let's focus on
that I don't want you to give that up
yet okay again just a beginner drill I'm
not saying that it is that but that's
what we want out of it okay try
it
okay um come on this side
all right so in this drill he's he's
really pushing push push push push push
push push push push I'm going to go a
little faster again okay push push push
push push push push push push okay I go
a little I'm going a little quicker than
you are okay got the got the idea okay
what what do you feel as you're doing
the drill like just I don't know what
you're going to say but just be studious
what do you feel constant pressure okay
you come
up you share your
feelings solid
okay
yeah cool all right you're going to come
over and you're going to touch the
triceps cuz that's the extension muscle
right the triceps okay you're going to
feel how old
ladyish I actually feel okay so you're
going to squeeze as we do the drill you
can use two hands you're not going to
you're not going to sexually assault me
here okay he's pushing and you see how
mushy it is right yes right it's the
same mushy here do you see same exact
mushy okay I come up keep mushing me
Andrew keep mushing me all over the
place mushing me all over the place
mushing on me all over the
place wishing
all okay
um the drill isn't going to work if
I'm that's not the drill okay the drill
is to get my body mind to realize it's
not what I think it is okay and so the
logic here again is if your if your hand
was able to hold out there it had
nothing to do with
tension and if your wrist is able to
have hold out there it had nothing to do
with forearm tension it had to do with
structural integrity and space of the
elbow so you could take that away if I
could take it away then that me it could
have stayed just relaxed the whole
forearm to make it old lady mushing okay
and then the same
thing the only reason this is in space
is because the shoulders in space got it
okay and so then I don't can I can take
that away we're not going anywhere and
then that would have meant that I don't
need upper arm tension I don't
need lower arm lower arm tension I don't
need hand tension don't think of it
faster cuz your your ego trip part mind
is going to go right back and you
all up okay um some other things things
for example if my shoulder is in space
we'll go a little
quicker on my shoulder okay he's driving
you got it he's driving I know and we're
not going to do it tonight but just want
to show you you're thinking that there's
a skeletal
alignment do do you understand like
you're thinking I'm sideways to
him but his line is over
my that shoulders that should line so it
doesn't it again doesn't matter if he's
somewhere else pushing at an angle you
see that he's I've not we're not on the
skeletal not on the skeletal alignment
and so if I if I wasn't on the skeletal
alignment he's driving drive drive drive
drive drive drive drive and it does I
don't even need the on you can do
whatever you
want you come in the middle which we
already know
right same thing you can take it off I
don't
go just hang out here boom same thing as
I go
back right
ready he he moov not not me okay
so it's not what we think it is and this
first
drill is a drill to get you out of what
you think it is
okay a lot of it does have to do with I
just can't get out
of thinking what it is and that's why I
want you to just think about what I told
you okay just the elements just do the
elements okay so when you come back out
obviously you don't have any arm
tense so put your arm back out without
the tension okay okay all right try it
again
let's pay attention to the coming back
out don't come back out with the same
tension come out easy peasy
go can speed up our transitions
now keep the same relaxation with the
same shoulder
Integrity in space
you can start having them drive
more lower drop that left shoulder drop
the
lat you try to P push homol laterally
Chris you can transition
if you need to cross laterally but push
homol
laterally so homolateral push you can
transition and now homolateral push on
the elbow let's go let's go good and
homolateral push on the elbow on the
shoulder push drop the drop the
lat then back out a little quicker stick
it out stick it out stick it
out and you're still in training don't
don't
don't mush on his
extension okay don't get don't try to
get out of all
right press from the floor
Chris climb up let's go Ronin give him
the elbow give him the elbow relax drop
the
shoulder give him the
elbow give him the wrist
again same side back
quicker quicker push
Drive
good stay in space stay on the same
midfoot
vector midfoot
midfoot back midfoot back
midfoot shoulders in
space shoulders and hips you kind of
open a little bit that that's for
later there it
is keep that shoulder there and just
extend your
arm there you go